jackie for more on this joining us now
former acting secretary for the dhs chad
wolfe mr secretary thank you for taking
time and what a perfect guess to to talk
about what we just heard from our great
reporter bill mollusian down there and
we was talking about the 650
migrants stopped in tamalepis
many of them half of them children
and i can't help but think it's
interesting that it coincided on the
same day that your counterpart secretary
mayorkus and secretary blinken were in
mexico talking about border security
issues what do you make of it
well i'd say the incident that we saw
with you know hundreds of migrants in
those tractor trailer trucks is just a
again another symptom
of this very inhumane
immigration and border policy that the
bite administration has again they don't
want to talk to you you don't see biden
administration officials or the
secretary or any other administration
official talking about that type of
seizure
and the pain and the dangerous journey
that those migraines are being put
through but they're doing that because
they know that the us border is open and
so the bite administration is sending
them a signal to take that dangerous
journey and i think that's wrong it
certainly needs to change look you know
whether you have the secretary of state
the dhs secretary and the attorney
general down there in mexico talking
about uh hopefully security and border
security but i know they're also talking
about a whole host of other issues these
are talks that happen
in any administration that happen all
the time the question though is was what
is changing on that border as a result
of those talks what is changing on the
enforcement posture both in the u.s and
in the on the mexico side
and i don't think that we're seeing any
differences we're certainly not seeing
any concrete
actions that they're taking as a result
of those talks well and that's why i was
so excited to speak with you because
what specifically if you were in
secretary my orchestra's
chair in mexico what would you ask
mexico for i just got back from the
mexico's southern border and portrayed
how open that is it is absolutely being
flooded and i'm gonna get on a plane in
a few hours and go to panama to the
darien gap where there are tens of
thousands of haitians on their way now
so so to be constructive what can mexico
do what should the u.s be asking for
well the mexican government can do a
variety of different things they can
close their southern border down to that
illegal migration that we see it's not
easy for them they don't have the same
resources and infrastructure that the
u.s has but it is doable they can deploy
their equivalent of the national guard
down there to stop individuals coming
across that southern border that don't
have the correct paperwork they can shut
that down they can shut down
they have a number of other
border checkpoints within the interior
of mexico they need to be properly
staffed but you need to enforce it time
and time again we've seen and heard of
reports where migrants come through
these border checkpoints or other
checkpoints in mexico they don't have
the right paperwork and yet they
continue on their journey you have to
enforce that they need to start flying
or repatriating folks from mexico back
to central america back to south america
back to haiti back to all the countries
that they're picking up so they not only
need to stop them and apprehend them and
detain them if they have no legal right
to be in mexico but then they need to
remove them from mexico back to their
home home countries instead of simply
releasing them for them to continue
on onto the southern border i want to
get your reaction
bill mollusion alluded to it and i
retweeted vice president harris's video
she put out of visiting
a day school visiting with these school
children literally
chad playing bingo with him on the day
that blink and mayorkas and merrick
garland are down in mexico trying to
solve the crisis your reaction
well again it's it's quite unbelievable
uh that you have the border czar who is
in charge of
she says not border security but she's
talking about the root causes of
migration that's what this team was
doing in mexico talking about some of
those root causes meeting with the
president of mexico so it's certainly at
the vice president's level to be down
there to be engaged on these discussions
and she's completely absent she's absent
from any follow-up to her previous uh
visit to guatemala and then and then to
mexico but also from the southern border
she's been to el paso which is not
seeing the vast majority of the illegal
crossings you know we need leadership
and we need leadership from the white
house which is lacking and from the
department which is lacking and i think
that's why you continue to see the same
failed border policy
month in and month out which is
delivering the same results you talk
about leadership mr secretary how can
they
get this under control and tell me how
this ends
well i think there's very specific
things that they can do again we left
them a road map on initiatives and
policies that worked whether that's the
remain of mexico program the asylum
cooperative agreements on unfortunately
just last night which we heard
you know canceling border wall uh
contracts in the in the rgv in the rio
grande valley there in texas which is
ground zero for the vast majority of
these illegal apprehensions and so in
the midst of a 21-year crisis high
crisis they decide to cancel border wall
uh contracts they decide to change ice
guidelines which they did last week
where you're not able to remove
individuals uh from the interior of the
country if they get past the border
patrol so again the bite administration
is carrying out an agenda
that is not pro-enforcement that is not
the rule of law they continue to
implement initiatives that continue to
allow and attract individuals to the
border it sure doesn't seem like it's
stopping any time soon former acting dhs
secretary chedwolf chad thank you